à parler des débordements des dérapages
les gilet jaune sutil victime ou
coupable
on vous pose la question pourrait
changer à d'ailleurs derrière moi la
question merci flory et aux équipes de
production
alors justement alexandre vous êtes levé
tout à l'heure vous étiez assez énervé
après ce jeune homme qui était avec nono
public qui nous disaient qu'ils étaient
contrôlés gilet jaune pour des raisons
c'est yanis 1 voilà il disait que vous
n'aviez aucun respect des valeurs de la
république aucun respect des libertés de
chacun et où ils disaient qu'on n'a pas
à nous forcer à aller manifester il
rappelé certaines lois qui lie les voilà
si on manifeste son voile à son prévenir
avec des règles strictes et ben il ya
bien sûr des possibilités d'amande donc
en fait moi je voulais intervenir par
rapport à la deuxième victime soit
disant qu'il a qu'il avance encore une
fois vous m'avez couper tout à l'heure
donc c'est dommage ça m'a calmé
[Rires]
qu'est ce qui se passe t-il été je vais
parler calmement et surtout dénoncé donc
pas les chiffres que nous sorte l'état
parce qu'ils sont faux on ne sait très
bien je vais dénoncer justement c'est ce
deuxième décès qu'il y ait donc à la
cause des gilles jeune donc il a été dit
par l'état puisque ça les arrange bien
puisque au moins ça fait peut-être
reculer le peuple à venir nous rejoindre
mais c'est totalement faux ce décès
n'est pas lié palier pallier au gilet
jaune
j'ai la famille qui me l'a confirmé
j'étais en contact avec eux avec ses
amis motards
c'est faux c'est archi faux donc qu'ils
peuvent là haut a enlevé ce décès qui
n'appartient pas au juge les jaunes
c'est un oui mais on comprend et c'est
vrai que voilà nous c'est ce qu'on parle
des débordements des dérapages la
actuellement dans les manifestations et
c'est vrai qu'on a on a tous peur de ce
qui va se passer on a appris il ya un
instant que voilà eric eric drew et nous
disait que vous alliez bloquer les
champs elysées demain on sait ce qui se
passe voilà ce qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'il a dit alors moi j'étais
derrière lui ce qu'il a bien ce qui l'a
clairement dit c'est mon marchera sur
les champs-elysées qu'est ce qu'on va
faire sur l'échangé de différer la
différence l'ua de l'hôtelier vous êtes
chez les jaunes mais anti blocage ou
alors moi clairement ça fait depuis
samedi que je fais une nuit sur deux
nuits blanches une petite équipe on
tourne avec des bagnoles ma bagnole à
est connue dans toute la ville et ont
tourné on tourne et je j'interviens
systématiquement auprès des gilets
jaunes qui font des blocages mais qui
n'ont qu'un sens d'accord par contre il
ya des choses qu'on peut faire
il ya des choses très intelligent donc
demain soir ils changent d'idée vous
avez vu ce marché pour l'instant pour
l'instant je vais pour marcher mais si
le mouvement était si le mouvement était
l'ancien beaucoup de monde forcément il
y aura des blocages ça va bloquer ah ben
moi tout dépend ce qui est ce qui est
proposé
on a toujours dit jusqu'à présent que
l'idée elle était clair elle était que
chacun pouvait mener de mener des
actions à partir de là s'il ya une
action qui moi me convient
personnellement j'aimais mon jaune et
j'y participe
d'accord contient me convient pas je me
désolidarise de ça parce que moi demain
comme vous avez entendu il ya voilà il
ya une soi-disant un deuxième décès pour
l'instant jean comptabilise 1 sur le
secteur d'angoulême clairement il n'y a
pas eu de décès on a essayé on a tenté
nous mettre un décès d'une dame âgée etc
c'était du bidon j'étais là à angoulême
on a mis une hotline en place avec un
numéro de téléphone
oui tout le monde l'avait la préfecture
n'a jamais voulu le relayer les services
de pompiers n'ont jamais entendu parler
de ce numéro est bizarrement tout le
monde là c'est à dire que on recevait
des appels et on essayé d'intervenir on
envoyait auprès de cette ambulance
on a envoyé des équipes de moto les
motos ont fait un travail extraordinaire
relayé d'ailleurs par une radio locale
qui s'appelle zigzags et qui a fait
vraiment un travail extraordinaire sur
place alors par contre
par contre ce qui est important de dire
c'est que il ya eu un démenti qui a été
fait derrière c'est très bien mais le
mal était fait et du coup l'opinion et
ben concrètement et belle s'est retourné
contre nous alors on va parler seulement
des débordements et des dérapages dans
les manifestations les gilet jaune sutil
victime ou coupable
vous allez nous dire un pour vous allez
les intervenants regardez c'est l'objet
de notre deuxième débat de la soirée et
on vous a tout résumé en vidéo regarde
cette semaine certains ont franchi la
ligne jaune depuis samedi dernier le
mouvement des gilet jaune est aussi
associée à ces mots qui reviennent
souvent dérapages et râpage dérive
déraper débordements avec des centaines
de milliers
français dans les rues de tels
débordements sont inévitables une
automobiliste a renversé donc une gilet
jaune mais certains incidents d'une
grande violence ternissent l'image du
mouvement comme des actes homophobes
les gilets jaunes près de bourg en
bresse qui saccagent la voiture d'un
couple d'hommes en les traitant de [ __ ]
ou encore des débordements racistes mais
aussi des actes antisémites au total 606
blessés dont dix sept graves parmi les
manifestants 134 parmi les forces de
l'ordre deux morts sont à déplorer
pour florian philippot cdc doivent
pousser le gouvernement à céder
c'est au gouvernement de calmer le jeu
en annonçant des choses extrêmement
concrètes pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français qui n'en peuvent plus dans tout
le pays les chiffres de la police sont
également très forts 795 interpellations
et 605 garde à vue et pour certains la
condamnation a directement été prononcé
quatre mois de prison ferme et quatre
mois de prison ferme quatre mois de
prison ferme une façon pour le
gouvernement de montrer l'exemple
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner a fermement condamné ces
débordements voit bien qu'on a une
dérive totale et aujourd'hui on voit
qu'on a une radicalisation entre les
policiers et les gilets jaunes la
situation est de plus en plus tendue la
situation dégénère pas ça tire son nom
mais pas seulement chez certains
français aussi le mouvement est mal reçu
plusieurs témoignages abondent sur les
réseaux sociaux pour dénoncer la
pression des gilet jaune
le hashtag balances ton gilet jaune a
même été créé pour recenser et dénoncé
les débordements de certains militants
ma femme accompagner nos deux enfants au
sport des filets jaunes se sont jetés
sur la voiture et ont éclaté une vitre
sont monté sur le capot les cris de mes
enfants n'ont rien empêché j'ai été
obligé de déposer mon gilet jaune sur
mon tableau de bord pour pouvoir passer
femmes seules face à une meute bas du
front j'ai dû m'exécuter écrit-elle et
je vous passe toutes les vidéos sur
lesquelles on entend clairement des
insultes à caractère raciste ou
homophobe des français bloqués sans
pouvoir négocier même dans des cas
d'urgence évidente
mais à qui la faute
pour certains membres du mouvement la
faute n'est pas à imputer au gilet jaune
on y va de son côté le gouvernement ne
compte pas laisser passer ces
débordements et veut se montrer ferme
est radical il faut être intraitable sur
l'ordre public
on a vu aujourd'hui 17h on entre
débordements et dérapages dans les
manifestations les gilets jaunes sont
ils victimes ou coupables les gilet
jaune sont ils victimes ou coupables
alors on a donc yoann qu'on a entendu il
ya un instant donc gilet jaune mais anti
blocage c'est très bien exprimer merci
d'être avec nous en tout cas on à côté
pierre louis étudiant en management du
sport anti gilet jaune participant actif
aux nouvelles hashtag balances ton gilet
jaune
on a en face yohan delattre merci d'être
là yoann avait rien à discuter un peu
aussi vous êtes chimiste vous êtes
porte-parole des gilet jaune à calais et
on a alors prends un risque vraiment
c'est vrai noam doit manoir policiers
délégué vigie police projet les jaunes
vous dépendez du ministère de
l'intérieur et pourtant vous soutenez
les filets jaunes je ne suis pas
favorable à aux étiquettes pour contre
et c'est pour moi la vie est un petit
peu plus compliqué que cette dichotomie
qu'on nous impose ses les choses sont un
peu plus nous est ancien des
renseignements généraux vous dépendez du
ministère de l'intérieur
oui est ce que vous prenez un risque en
venant dire ce soir en direct sur notre
plateau que vous êtes donc vous êtes
soutenez les gilet jaune ce que c'est la
position du syndicat que je représente
ici ce soir vigie police que nous sommes
deux syndicats à avoir tenu des
positions
qu'on pourrait qualifier de favorable à
ce mouvement de contestation il ya le
syndicat sgp unité qui a appelé le 17
novembre dernier à une journée sans pv
donc sans verbalisation ça c'est ce
qu'on avait vu et nous sur le principe
effectivement on défend les
revendications du peuple français parce
que notre premier serment en tant que
policier c'est la défense des
institutions républicaines et le service
au peuple français et je ne fais pas
contrairement à certains invités puisque
j'ai écouté la première partie de
l'émission
la distinction aussi net est aussi
claire entre les gilet jaune et peuple
français pour moi messieurs dames vous
êtes le peuple français
effectivement nous sommes en démocratie
mais nous sommes avant tout une
institution à votre service au service
de votre sécurité met à votre service un
service public donc pour moi les choses
sont assez claires alors noan vous en
plus j'ai vraiment besoin d'avoir et
avoir envie d'avoir votre avis pour vous
les jets les jeunes sont ils victimes ou
coupables et que le gilet jaune c'est la
france
pour mme oda alors dans le débat que
vous venez de poser ils sont victimes
parce que moi je suis un technicien du
droit en tant que policier mais je crois
en la responsabilité individuelle c'est
à clichy sous bois quand on a eu des
émeutes en 2005 est ce qu'on s'est dit
bon ça brûle des voitures à clichy donc
si vous habitez clichy vous êtes
responsable des voitures brûlées on vous
interpelle ça n'existe pas en droit
donc il ya des personnes qui ont commis
des délits des violences volontaires par
avec arme par destination c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle le fait de rentrer dans la
foule avec des voitures et des ddt le
délit principalement constitué c'est
aussi celui de participation à un
attroupement non autorisées bon soit jeu
voilà donc nombreux c'est de l'ordre de
la responsabilité individuelle mais je
vois pas l'intérêt de ce débat de dire
est ce que tous les gilets jaunes sont
coupables d'infractions dans le bizarre
parce que quand on dit victime ou
coupable c'est qu'aussi les gilet jaune
quand il ya des camps il ya des
débordements comme ça c'est pas
forcément des gens qui sont dans le
mouvement et des gens et voit la porte
j'ai envie de dire qu'il soit dans le
mouvement ou pas vous commettez une
infraction l'état et line est sérieuse
mais sa part toit du bus et on appelle
les gens vous aviez le droit ça porte
préjudice aux messages que à l'image et
à l'image que pour cliché mais ça c'est
peut-être la volonté certains médias de
mettre en avant
puisqu'on a eu 280 mille personnes en
rassemblés samedi dernier ce sont les
chiffres du mid term intérieur je sais
pas combien vous en parlais tout à
l'heure du tapis maison qui crament il
délit à ce que je sache donc pourquoi
est ce qu'on parle pas des 275 mille
cinq cents personnes qui se sont bien
comportées et ont mais l'âge elles ont
fait écran d'entre eux ont trouvé que
les médias font du sensationnalisme
écoutez venez moi j'ai travaillé et ça
me sert ni aux renseignements généraux
de seine-saint-denis
c'est un département particulièrement
criminogènes donc les vols de sacs à
main les détériorations de véhicules etc
c'est malheureusement le quotidien des
gens qui dans ce département on n'en
parle pas ou on en parle assez peu toute
l'année là quand on a un mouvement de
contestation qui politiquement peut
sembler légitime mais on peut avoir des
contestations des revendications haut
depuis une semaine c'est un bombardement
incessant de d'appel à la responsabilité
et c'est monsieur naulleau permettez moi
de vous contredire tout à l'heure mais
vous disiez des gilets jaunes vous
voulez modifier la loi en appelant à la
violer mais est ce que les personnes qui
sont ici systématiquement appel à la
violation de la loi je n'en suis pas sûr
eric soin d'en douter voulant manifester
dans des lieux non autorisée en
déclarant pas les manifestations oui la
préfecture il ya une violation de la loi
je voudrais alors permettez permettait
aux techniciens du renseignement que
j'ai pu être de l'écrire sujet là c'est
un mouvement spontané populaire il n'a
pas de représentant de qui aujourd'hui
est légitime pour déclarer représenter
ce mouvement le jour où on déterminera
laissez moi juste deux secondes pour
terminer mais le jour je peux vous me
dire à l'avancé le jour on déterminera
des pseudo responsables pour représenter
ce mouvement est qu on les recevra en
délégation en disant bas c'est bon de
gagner fin ce sera une escroquerie et ce
sera la fin de ces étranges comme ça
qu'on retient un mouvement sans meneur
peut se dispenser de respecter la
revendication est claire il n'y a pas
besoin de bonheur les revendications
elles sont écrites noir sur blanc les
gens il ya eu ya une goutte d'eau qui a
fait déborder un vase
certes on peut effectuer l'augmentation
du crb mais la goutte d'eau mais il ya
quand même un vase bien remplie rire
c'est un autre débat oui même débat
s'est alors alors alors qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que tu as répondu eric
noni réussi dans la vie mais je crois
qu'à des personnes qui malheureusement
ne réussissent pas et c'est la majorité
des français aujourd'hui
saluons avec la classe moyenne avait pas
que l'émission porté sur moi mon succès
des barbelés tout l'été alors justement
johan vous êtes chimiste porte parole du
gilet jaune à calais j'aimerais d'abord
qu'on parle de votre situation dont vous
êtes chez ministre vous avez quel âge et
yoann j'ai 50 ans cinquante ans et
quelqu'un on va vous voyagez vous
demandez-vous gagné combien par mois
je suis bas c'est compliqué je travaille
depuis l'âge de 15 ans j'ai démarré
j'étais boucher charcutier traiteur
j'étais cuisinier
j'ai travaillé un peu dans l'électricité
j'ai parti j'ai parti en 89 dans une
industrie chimique
donc j'ai fait plein de choses et j'y
suis resté j'étais licencié en 2013 au
bout de 25 ans de deux boîtes d'accord
aujourd'hui vous en sortez pas bah c'est
à dire que pendant cinq ans où j'ai été
une période pendant un an j'ai envoyé
250 cv pour trouver du taf je suis
reconverti j'ai passé le permis sur le
permis super lourd je suis parti faire
l'international d'accord et la boîte qui
m'a licencié m'a rappelé de cette année
au mois d'avril en cdi d'accord et donc
là aujourd'hui qu'elle est calé quel est
votre souci et pourquoi vous dites que
les gilets jaunes sont victimes
ben pourquoi elles sont ils sont vite et
me bon ce qui amène je veux dire ce qui
discrédite que les gilet jaune
bref non par deux voilà deux clubs de
bonne foi dont on en a marre des taxes
comme tout le monde le sait c'est la
presse et la presse locale la presse
nationale c'est la télévision les
journalistes qui eux qui sont là pour
faire du sensationnel
dès qu'il ya débordement ont fait l on
passe à la télévision mais avoue t su ni
fonds non mais coûte mais à écouter
écouter ceux qui font du bon boulot
comme nous on l'a fait sur calais on
avait fait un deal parce que le blocage
était interdite non affable haut avec le
sous préfet de calais en concertation
avec les rt enseignement les rejets avec
le commission commissariat central vous
aviez panne il pas la porte à tous peut
paraître structure est organisée juste
pour seulement pour la journée du 17
oui parce que depuis ça continue et donc
on a bloqué nous pensions n'a fait dire
que la sous préfecture parce que chez
nous on le sait on à l'a16 qui traverse
boulogne jusqu'à dunkerque viala qui
vient de belgique et on a ce flux
migratoires donc il ne fallait
absolument pas que les camions s'arrête
sur cette autoroute
pour dire d'avoir des dégradations de
camions de bien sûr je parce qu'ils
veulent résolument partie en angleterre
donc on a fait a dit mais nous on a
vraiment bloqué nous on a vraiment
bloqué ce qu'on appelle cité europe car
tous ont cité europe
auchan et c'est tous ces magasins ont
fermé pour la plupart à 16 heures mais
même à 14h ce que vous dites oui parce
que vous êtes un beau gilet jaune comme
l'immense majorité qui est là pour
défendre ses droits c'est pas le sujet
c'est vraiment pas moi en tout cas ce
que je pense je dis juste pour la
responsabilité des médias vous oublié
quand même qu'on ait à un moment où il
ya les réseaux sociaux et que tous les
médias et journalistes et tout le monde
relaie des ces situations qui ont eu
lieu
c'est par la sema les puissants 80 des
formes mes propos je suis pas d'accord
quand il ya des émissions qui font un
million de vues il ya des réseaux
sociaux qui balancent des vidéos qui
sont vus 4 millions que je voudrais
juste dire pour paco ça déforme mon
propos c'est que malheureusement parce
que le vote mais s'agit il est important
vous ne maîtrisez pas la chose et vous
on a vu qu'à l'intérieur des réseaux
sociaux quad et gilet jaune pardon sans
fil très des groupes politiques sur le
filtrage des gens qui ce comportement
est témoin synergis parce que qui si du
court laissez moi juste terminée si
c'est une vérité la femme qui a subi les
propos racistes est une réalité et c'est
parce que ponte l'immensité des gilet
jaune
donc ça veut dire que ça fausse votre
message alors et malheureusement malgré
vous donc c'est pour ça que je mets ni
victime ni coupable parce que vous le
subissent et de la même manière sa
fausse complètement votre bios âme et on
croule vous êtes des casseurs moi j'ai
eu un commerce bas avenue daumesnil
c'est la commencer toutes les
manifestations il ya plein de casseurs
qui se met devant et qui impressionne
ceux qui viennent porter un vrai
discours qui viennent pour casser et qui
vous font du tort ça ça existe
donc oui allez j'y vois je vais vous
dire je suis dit au peuple et on a une
super bande a été structuré organisé
d'ailleurs je peux faire je peux tous
les féliciter sur calais stephan angers
les cas moi aussi je peux citer des
prénoms
jean mokhtar merci mollet et donc tous
ces gens là on a tous travaillé ensemble
je peux vous dire qu'il ya eu aucun il
ya eu des petits mais rien c'était e
minime si on a super bien fait enrager
si serré a passé on a été félicité par
l'energy par le préfet alors je suis dit
muhammad vous dit coupable oui parce que
faut être honnête la force de ce
mouvement c'est sa spontanéité
ce mouvement citoyen qui à la base est
apolitique et qui est demain être en
train d'être récupérées n'oubliez pas
que ceux qui nous ont mis dans cette
situation qui seront demain dans les
rues c'est la gauche et la droite est
désormais cherche à récupérer ce
mouvement
le problème c'est que cette force de
spontanéité en effet votre plus grande
faiblesse
ce mouvement qui a été désorganisée a eu
des conséquences dramatiques
alors peut-être que on peut se dire que
sur les 280 mhz il y en a eu 279 me qui
sont bien comportés mais il ya eu deux
morts et on peut pas se renvoyer les
morts en lisant la deuxième mort
ce n'est pas moi c'était finalement un
autre n'oubliez pas que une personne
âgée une personne qui venait d'être à la
retraite un gilet jaune était en train
de manifester lorsque une dame qui
cherchait à amener son enfant chez
médecin a été pris à partie par des
gilets aux jeunes qui ont tapé sur sa
voiture est prise d'une attaque de
panique elle s'est mis à accélérer ces
dames est morte
ces dames est morte alors qu'elle avait
des enfants des petits enfants et la
dame en face car la dame en face les
mollahs oui oui à la halle à renverser
nadal à robin la panique et on pourra
dire le moyen on ne peut pas dire que
c'est tout on peut pas généraliser
bernard laporte pour les avoir côtoyés
toute la semaine on l'a dit rodi ce sont
des gens bien qui sont dans le calme qui
a des chocs pas de violence externe
malheureusement dans tout ça il ya
toujours des exceptions
il ya toujours des crises oriola alors
que la mairie fixe et veilleront
uniforme que ça dérape un certain moment
s'il vous plaît vous parlez vous parliez
de scène le destin d'une manifestante en
savoie a été percutée donc par une
conductrice qui on est donc s'afficher
le médecin c'est ce que vous avez dit
elle a été prise de panique quand les
manifestants ont commencé à taper sur sa
voiture a alors foncé sur eux et percuté
une femme sa fille avait d'ailleurs
réagi dans les médias regardez
pea énergique
plein de vie
une primé
mais
agi avec les d'autres c'était
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de bien je dis
pas ça le ski c'est ma maman mais c'est
fou ça c'est un vrai après débordement
ça c est la panique et donc c'est vrai
classés c'est un peu voilà c'est vrai
qu'on déplore compliqué et tout le monde
le déplore cette situation ne faut pas
généraliser
oui c'est un mouvement c'est un
mouvement de gens qui sont calmes qui ne
veulent pas de virage et c'est
malheureusement à l'intérieur de ça
comme toujours il ya des gens ici se
comporte mal et ils arrivent les
incidents où il est arrivé à la maison
ne veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas les
écrits mines et ils sont bien filmé de
chats doit vous qui êtes policier et
ancien des renseignements généraux
moi j'ai une question à vous poser
demain quand higuain qui sur les champs
vous pensez qu'il va voir des
débordements ou pas effectivement je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
envisagée par la préfecture de police
alors il ya moi j'ai eu accès à des
informations de la part d'anciens
collaborateurs qui me dit bon clairement
les craintes se sont se sont pas les il
faut arrêter de fantasmer sur l'idée que
les gens qui se plaignent de ne pas
pouvoir faire leur plein à la fin de la
semaine vous me descendre de bordeaux
jusqu'à paris pour manifester
la majorité des gens sont fauchés cède
le rassemblement parisien il va pas être
à voir l'ampleur escomptée
ça va être un rassemblement qui va
concerner principalement des franciliens
peut-être des gens de grâce à ron ça va
se limiter à ça alors et ensuite on va
avoir des infiltrations très minoritaire
de personnes issues de l'ultra droite -
ultra gauche on a des groupes constitués
et des banlieusards qui malheureusement
se saisissent de toutes les opportunités
qu'elles soient festifs au ventre au nez
des banlieusards voilà certains oui
c'est pas les banlieusards des
banlieusards mais ça ils franchissent le
périphérique
effectivement on a des gens qui sont
identifiés comme étant des pilleurs ils
sont ils ces arrivées à bobigny côte ya
eu des manifestations dans le cas de la
ferté oh ça arrivait après la coupe du
monde ça arrive systématiquement ya
aucune raison que ça change
on pense qu'ils seront là et la
préfecture dans hills a mis en place
n'ont rien et connaissez vous les avez
donc méfiez vous savez qu'il faut pas
voir là si d'aventuré vous parlez vous
avez qui s'est maintenant c'est que ça
va arriver c'est inéluctable savez si
exotique mais je les connais pas non
c'est pas mes amis c'est d'où ils
viennent
non j'ai pas dit c'est vous dire
exactement mais vous dites on l'est tous
deux ont dit ça on sait d'où il vient
donc vous les connaissez bah écoutez il
ya juste les blu ray avant l'heure
jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas de
après je les aurai perdre engage que moi
n'y a pas de délit d'intention on peut
pas arrêter avant c'est bon alors la loi
alors eric revel vous des victimes
oui oui j victimes parce que c'est très
intéressant auquel ils policier éric
revel muay thaï beach ou presque même si
j'ai dit stop tht heures jeudi victime
là parce qu'il semble que on est en
train de monter en exergue ddd ainsi
dramatique qui vont jusqu'à la mort mais
qui n'illustre pas du tout mouvement
d'aidé gilet jaune mais ce que j'entends
dans les propos du policier m'intéresse
beaucoup parce que l'une des raisons
aussi pour lesquels peut-être le
ministère de l'intérieur a proposé le
champ de mars c'est qu'on sait que c'est
une pelouse qui peut contenir jusqu'à
500 mille personnes si vous avez sur les
images que trente ou quarante mille
personnes peut-être qu'on dira que c'est
un échec
y a pas de commerce l'on attendait non
mais je n'en ai jamais d'autre chose est
sûre sur la discussion sur les chiffres
exacts
elle est très intéressante aussi parce
que souvent dans les manifestations vous
avez syndicats plus ministère de
l'intérieur leschi des syndicats sont
beaucoup plus importants celui ci à
l'intérieur sont diminués en général ce
que font les médias il prenait deux
chiffres il additionne il vise par deux
il essaie d'avoir une idée là il ya un
seul chiffre donne celui du mystère
l'intérieur parce que précisément la
manif amateurs non mais ça veut dire que
sans doute on peut le dire le le
comptage est sujet à caution
alors non alors est-ce qu'ils sont
victimes ou coupables on va avoir la vie
de karim zeribi dans un instant je
dirais même si tous les bijoux et pour
voir si ou pierrick j'aurais qu'on voit
la vidéo qui a fait le buzz samedi
dernier c'est un conducteur qui avait
renversé renversé un policier
puisqu'on parle des débordements des
dérapages regarder
alors qu'harry moi je crois que le
mouvement dans son immense majorité est
victime du comportement et de quelques
comportements isolés mais inacceptable
qui effectivement ternissent le
mouvement parce qu'ils sont montés en
épingle comme étant effectivement pas
isolé quand je regarde la salle tout ce
qui porte le gilet jaune je pense qu'ils
sont assez à l'image de ceux qui sont
dans la rue sur le mécontentement
aujourd'hui qui monte
je vois pas des délinquants je vois pas
des gens qui ont envie de casser je vois
des gens qui à un moment donné demande
de du respect de l'écouté de la tension
de la considération
je vois des gens qui plutôt se lève le
matin mutuellement et je voulais je les
vois pas se transforme en casseurs alors
un style et des casseurs isolé des
groupuscules je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
je les dis à eric moi je crains les
champs elysées parce que je crois qu'à
des professionnels de la casse qui vont
traiter polluer le mouvement et le
mouvement doit être guy gilain à sa part
greg qui youtuber gilet jaune vidéo il
arrive il a fait une vidéo qui a été vue
plus de presque 2 millions de fois vous
êtes exposé merci d'être là greg alors
ça vous vous alors bien sûr juste levé
ça parce que j'ai l'impression que j'ai
eue de victimes bien sûr dans les états
bordant la mer je mettrais m'arrive
réussite
ah bon juste avant voilà avant la pause
il y avait pierre louis qui est étudiant
en management du sport anti gilet jaune
qui est un participant actif au hashtag
ballon long gilet jaune qui nous disait
qu'il était vraiment contre le mouvement
voilà totalement sûr alors sur autant
sur le fond je comprends certaines
revendications certaines causes qui me
semble légitime notamment sur le pouvoir
d'achat autant après sur la forme
pour moi il ya des contradictions total
sur certains blocages sont admissibles
et d'autres non j'ai entendu ça non un
blocage c'est pas admissible c'est pas
légal donc à maintenant ce n'est pas
légal ce n'est pas admissible
de la même façon quand il ya des
revendications qui sont sur mâcon
d'émissions sur la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale sur un référendum
de légitimité du président c'est pareil
c'est pas acceptable on peut pas se
permettre dans une démocratie dans une
république de remettre en cause la
parole des jantes la liste de ce qui est
admissible ou pas parce que
malheureusement à cause des gilet jaune
ya beaucoup de choses qui ne sont pas
admissibles exiger la liste de ce qui
est admissible la loi comme chez la loi
démocrate est en plus un autre 50 ans de
la loi
oui bien sûr je veux dire voilà donc
maintenant s'est clarifiée donc les
gilets jour sont tous des hors-la-loi
n'ont pas tous voila pas tous mais déjà
toutes les personnes qui sont hors la
loi doivent obligatoirement soit se
conformer à la loi soit être jugés si
jamais ils commettent une infraction et
c'est la même règle pour tout le monde
et c'est pas parce que c'est des gilets
jaunes c'est la même règle pour tous les
citoyens français et ensuite la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il y en a aussi qui
cautionnent qu'ils ne sont pas hors la
loi mais qui accepte qu'ils tolèrent m
280 mille personnes en garde à vue le
samedi 17 cas c'est pas comme ça crame
un nom mêlé
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs moi je sais vous les voyez
s'il vous plaît abbas évolué ville est
agitée la veille
alors votre boîte quoi faire une haie
gilet jaune
je crois qu'il faut il faut se garder de
moi je suis un peu on va dire entre
guillemets ben je me fais volontairement
parfois un peu l'avocat du diable
oui mais si vous voulez je suis un petit
peu quand même a interloqué par ce que
j'entendais parce que j'entends parler
par exemple de bons gilet jaune depuis
l'émission de jean bien de choses
admissibles ou pas donc etc des
jugements de valeur à mon sens on est
sur notre ambition vous d'autres
maintenant je vous écoute je suis terre
il s'est trompé de métier fait des
ressources humaines ça vous conviendra
peut-être eric eric non mais une limite
très nette entre un comportement licite
un cocon s'entendant illicites et on est
tous d'accord ici c'est parce que vous
essayez dans les cévennes mais
d'introduire comme izany on est mais oui
parce que ça nous échappe parfois vous
avez plusieurs et on est d'accord et on
est d'accord quelques noms mais jamais
pour tout le monde pareil pour vous et
regardez surtout finir la phrase mais
celle ci si c'est pas un délit mais un
délit ok je suis mauvais allez on est
sûr qu'il gagnait 1 19% du gilet jaune
qui sont dans la loi mais il ya des
comportements illicites et vous avez
l'air de les excuser moi ça fait partie
du problème c'est ce déni qui me dérange
nation il a je suis pour la
responsabilité individuelle et que ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'une
personne qui commet un délit doit être
interpellé
je sors monsieur a besoin de vous qui
avait été justement services les
renseignements généraux
et encore une fois je suis pas contrôler
gilet jaune je suis plutôt pour pour ce
qu'ils défendent
je sors demain j'ai ma petite fille je
me balade et je veux aller dans un
endroit mais un individu comme moi
qu'elles mêmes droits que moi a le droit
de me bloquer et de m'interdire de
passer de main en croire alors il ya une
démarche qui est bien simple en général
il ya des barrages policiers jusqu'à
didier gambier vous désigner les
personnes qui font obstruction à votre
liberté d'aller et venir aux policiers
et les policiers sont bien dans leurs
devoirs va faire mieux quand même type
il ya pas de 500000 personnes qui font
réagir c'est à dire qu'il ya justement
là on entre dans des considérations pas
touchés avaient déposé plainte parce
qu'ils n'ont normalement il ya l'article
73 du code de procédure pénale qui
permet aux policiers d'intervenir
directement vous puissiez les retrouvera
dans le cas de communes des lilas
voilà mais a priori comme je vous dis
aussi une façon d'être réalistes qu'à la
théorie et la pratique je crois que si
on se on avait un discours basé sur
l'aspect théorique du code de procédure
pénale on passerait notre temps à
interpeller les personnes jouent et
soulagé parce que je pense qu'il faut
faire preuve d'un peu plus de réserve je
veux dire être un délégué syndical ça
n'autorise pas tout un premier roman
d'accord a expliqué non mais c'est très
simple il ya le respect de la loi et le
respect de l'ordre
voilà et on a beau avoir des motivations
des revendications tout ça ça peut
s'exprimer dans le cadre de la loi
je le répète il ya une liberté de
manifester voilà donc il faut pas dévier
le propos il ya des débordements et des
bandes excessivement grave alors tu veux
leur montrer un autre regard d un
automobiliste qui a été la cible de
propos racistes ça et c'est un énorme
buzz
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors voyez le parquet d'angoulême
a ouvert une enquête ça s'est très bien
passé après les personnes sont
interpellées et la responsabilité
déterminer oui mais je vois pas ou rions
pas mal on parle des débordements on
parle de en fait l'un des rallyes mais
quand il ya des débordements comme ça ça
ternit les mythes et gilet jaune cc
derrière sur le terrain on aurait dit
des jaunes revient la responsabilité des
médias unanimes les médias sont aussi
mis en péril si vous en verrez que vous
faites ça change il ya des gens
structure à tous en même temps nous a
pas besoin de jouer
on est unanime pour dire à tanger les
hommes gagnent on est unanime pour dire
que ça pour nous c'est pas des raisons
mais bien sûr que les sens la commune
ses passages au bisphénol a et cécile
tandis que ti jean giono on n'aime pas
ça c'est comme en ce moment il ya
beaucoup de vidéos qui tournent sur les
crs et on jouait tous les crs ont comme
ça ils plus des dieux et tout cela parce
que les crs il fait ça quand tous les
crs comme ça donc faut arrêter de
stigmatiser le mans des zélés des
événements qui amasse que je vous
garantis que moi samedi j'étais sur le
terrain comme dirait ma cran très bien
passé mais quand ceux ci ont filtré ont
barré pas ce que fut créée voilà déjà
n'y a pas de barrage ce qu'avait des
titrages commandant naples au gré des
gens y avaient même il y avait même un
monsieur marc un film a pris pour des
jambons et aux malades croyez rien une
paupière là bas donc moi je vais donc
moi j'y vais j'ai beaucoup moins choqué
destexhe pompiers je suis pompier
volontaire d'accord ex mari pompier et
chaque jeune homme pompiers volontaires
d'accord la caserne sursis les pays que
je salue et donc j'étais assez tôt cv
quand même un des participants y est
donc
par curiosité bon ça va tu vas être j
mais c'était un agent de sécurité de son
pull rouge sécurité civile ouais j'ai
pas dire et c'est pas une bonne chose du
passé je savais qu'il me prenait pas les
baisser oui alors vous êtes alors alors
c'est bon ça fonctionne là vraiment ça
c'est voilà alors du coup moi je
m'appelle louis boyard du coup m
inquiète ça va se passer bien week
mais en fait vous êtes vous êtes qui
alors moi du coup je suis loyal je suis
président d'un syndicat lycéen et jeu
truqué mais on parle vous êtes pour ou
contre l'egypte
justement en fait c'est ce que je vais
expliquer c'est que l'on parle des gilet
jaune on parle de la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat toutes ces choses là mais faut
aussi rappeler que par exemple dans les
hôpitaux
ça fait des mois et des mois qu'il ya
des gens qui sont en grève justement
parce qu'il crève dans les hôpitaux
face à elle n'ordonne pas des moyens
nous dans les lycées ça fait un an que
on se mobilise
il ya cent dix lycéens qui ont fini en
taule parce qu'ils sont mobilisés et là
on n'a pas non plus parlé de nous non
plus en fait et les jeunes on parle pas
du tout nous et j'aimerais aussi parlé
d'un autre humain vie s'il y avait
laissé dans le mouvement des jeunes ya
détenir d'être étonnant à regarder
voilà la grecque il ya plein de choses
il ya plein de gens qui se sont greffés
au mouvement des gels et jaune ya des
infirmières il ya des lycéens mais dont
tout le monde se greffent au mouvement
il représente la france
non mais pardonnez moi mais je moi
jusque là programme que j'ai si vous
voulez c'est qu'on essaye de pas au
travers de vos je vois que en pot
défendre ma position
il ya des accusations il ya des coups
sous la ceinture si je puis dire
et en fait là le vrai débat c'est la
criminalisation finalement de la pensée
d'opposition c'est à dire qu'on a déjà
s'oppose à et finalement une mesure qui
a été prise une mesure s'est tenu un
discours que vous tenez ces délires ou
par un représentant de la loi c'est dire
les leaders et jaune et gilet jaune pour
donner mon avis sont des romans ils sont
doublement victimes victimes de la
violence sociale est parfois victime de
la violence physique parce que quand on
force un barrage mais tout le monde est
triste que vous allez entendre et c'est
moi faire ici hier sur l'énigme elle
essaie d'obtenir laissez vous pas tout
fait un one man show avait laissé
derrière les gilets jaunes et vous aussi
vous êtes compact de dénis ya déni de
tout ce qui va pas là vous êtes en train
de relativiser les manquements à la loi
et les violations de la loi venant d'un
policier - sam estomaqué absolument je
finis aussi je regardais gilet jaune
il ya un déni aussi de tous les gens qui
vous ont infiltré je regrette l'extrême
droite à infiltrer ce mouvement le
campus est lécousse le pousse vers des
cours
le finistère des comportements tels que
ce qu'on a entendu ces insultes racistes
et homophobes ne viennent pas de chez
vous ils viennent de gens infiltré chez
larousse qui représente l'extrême gauche
dans la surface
j'en entend tous les jours et pourtant
ils ont pas un jaune sur eux c'est la
vie de tous les jours c'est la vie des
français dans son terrain je finis
souvent été à un moment donné mais vous
êtes coupable de tous et dénis de même
que j'entends beaucoup d'accusations sur
les gens autour de cette table
j'attendais accusations des médias les
médias ou été une formidable caisse de
radio vous savez les médias rouffet
cette manifestation riche ont fait le
succès c'est le troisième larron bouet
c'est parce que ça fait de l'audience
mais arrêtez d'accuser tout le monde
toutes les élites parce qu'il ya des
gens qui leur arrive alors s'ils
apprennent à jésus te mords et je vous
ai le droit entendu pendant ce policier
paradoxal
j'aimais gimontois cela s'avère déjà
s'il vous plaît on aura connu tout à
l'heure et 40 jérémy ce que je voudrais
si c'est qu'on ramène les choses dans
leur proportion il y avait trois cent
mille personnes dans la rue c'était les
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
ouais nos amis j'ai les jeunes disent y
en avait beaucoup plus mais partant des
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur si
vous voulez bien trois cent mille
personnes
s'il ya eu 300 de dérapage ça fait 0,1
pour ça est-ce qu'on doive s'arrêter sur
0,9 pour cent de comportements
inacceptables condamné d'ailleurs parce
qu'il ya déjà eu des condamnations sont
tombées et les jeunes ici les condamne
eux-mêmes pour oublier 99,9 pour cent du
rouble et la réponse est non car ce
museau crise évidemment que ce mouvement
n'est pas un mouvement violent
sinon dites vous bien que ce serait la
guerre civile dans le pays
parce que nous parle de politique on est
complètement apolitique on est vraiment
le peuple voisin du poignant oui oui on
a vu avec leur micro leurs filets jaunes
ont les vomis ces genres de salta nous
donnerons tout ce que vous avez déjà vu
des mets derrière dupont aignan avec ses
tracts du spd a déjà vu des jeunes
derrière joan boix beaux ils sont jeunes
ils vont s'en foutent du poignant mais
il est le héros du jour s'appelle alors
c'est vrai qu'on a entendu vous pouvez
passer le micro
non mais s'il vous plaît et interview p
500 qui ont pu lui parler dans le micro
faut parler dans le micro
or vous savez ça fait comme ça fait un
an que les lycéens se mobilisent
on parle d'un visibilisation il ya un
truc dont vous parlez pas demain il ya
aussi une marche contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes on n'en parle pas
versus violence dans les violences dans
les hôpitaux on a parle pas les
violences contre des jeunes on ne parle
pas les ehpad on en parle bien sûr on
fait un public ici on n'en parle pas ici
des seuls porte parole c'est des gens
qui touchent à 1,7 million fin et de
parents il faut arrêter de déconner et
aujourd'hui on dit gilet jaune paille y
est pas et gilet jaune arrêter les
étiquettes aujourd'hui on a ça en commun
qui a une colère chez soi guerre lasse
pas s'exprimer quand vous dites est
hélas a fait ça fait ça fait sans
déconner ça fait deux heures qu'on est
ici à faire les pots de fleurs moi
j'aime bien faire de mon vendredi et
vous des fois on m'avait dit qu'on
m'avait dit que je pouvais venir pour
parler des jeunes je peux pas parler des
jeunes
on est ici attentes envers les pots de
fleurs pendant deux heures mais calmez
vous j'ai mieux à faire de vendredi sont
venus pour faire de la balle et bat
partait ça fait deux heures que vous
êtes là pour vous on vous écoute n'avait
donné que c'est une habitude qu'il y
avait des bonbons haribo la mi temps
méchaal beaucoup aidé le micro il nous a
fait une sortie il nous a fait mal je
sais pas ils valent en bois qui vole en
bois à mon avis il a eu un sms tu biloba
la soirée bon attendues tardent à futuna
six mois la 2009 c'est pas des faits et
eroglu tu viens la soirée 11 aides en
deux ans mais bien sûr qu'on écoute les
autres vous dis élan il a il a dit un
truc vais y a plein d'autres mouvements
demain c'est vrai qu'ils sont à la marge
pour maggie d'ailleurs bientôt
exactement pour maggy hausse s'avère
voilà et donc c'est vrai que ça serait
complet si on fait pas tous en même
temps et donc c'est vrai qu'il ya plein
d'autres
il ya plein d'autres mouvements et c'est
vrai que c'est important aussi dans le
public
quelqu'un j'ai vu j'ai vu une jeune
femme qui était extrêmement énervé quel
est votre prénom moi c'est emmanuel
bonsoir emmanuel hoog est magnifique je
vais vous dire même le gilet jaune voire
très bien et chat dans la gorge et moi
on a failli faire un soir les salles et
l'idée d'aller chez lui alors les ia
l'histoire pas beaucoup donc forcément
c'est normal allez dites mais depuis le
début de la soirée en fait on entend
beaucoup de choses
oui je crois que le font en fait il ya
max ne le comprennent pas on est des
jeunes en effet mais c'est pas parce que
il y en a qui vont être plus du côté fn
ou de la gauche de la droite que on a
dit qu'on allait mettre une étiquette on
en a rien à [ __ ]
on ne veut pas non plus de syndicats qui
nous mobilisent qu'ils nous disent il
faut que vous alliez là ou là parce que
si justement derrière il va y avoir une
étiquette et ça on n'en veut pas c'est
le mouvement citoyen tous les jours en
fait ce sont des gens qu'ils soient
jeunes ou vieux qui se déplacent qui
vont oui faire des bouclages ou des
filtrages noah toulouse par exemple ça
se passe très bien
il ya une solidarité que je crois que
vous vous rendez même pas compte à quel
point c'est tout chaud mais moi je les
vois tous les jours parce que des fois
je vais les rencontrer parce que oui
peut y avoir des petits litiges entre
eux mais ça c'est des choses qui
arrivent année
porte quel mouvement que ça soit une
grève qu'ils soient déclarés ou pas et
là en fait il ya une france qui est en
train de se retrouver dans la solidarité
tous les jours il ya des gens qui
s'arrêtent au niveau des péages qui vont
leur donner à manger ne serait qu ils
vont lui passer des couvertures parce
qu'ils sont justement avec nous et ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on est en train
de réussir à faire et qui gêne tout le
monde sait qu'on est en train d'unir le
benjamin fall reconnaît très belle
intervention ballon mademoiselle oui je
veux dire qu est ce qu ils sont victimes
ou coupables pour moi ils sont victimes
victimes de leur succès et c'est un
succès indéniable mise à part évidemment
les débordements on est d'accord je
voulais dire aussi que pendant toute la
semaine qui s est écoulé le gouvernement
volontairement ils sont dans son rôle
ils ont voulu appuyer sur les
débordements on veut critiquer les
médias on en parlera tout à l'heure on
va en parler selon la médiatisation du
gouvernement le ministère de l'intérieur
ils ont voulu appuyer sur les
débordements pour pouvoir calmer et ils
sont dans leur rôle mais fois par aussi
conscience de cette volonté d'appuyer
sur ce qui n'allait pas il ya une
réponse cette semaine sécuritaire pas de
réponse politique tout le monde attend
toujours la réponse politique
et puis il faut encore signaler pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils sont victimes
individuellement et là je rejoins noam
individuellement les débordements et les
vous en servir honte oui non le jeu
connaîtra pas surtout pas sciotot vous
avions des individus helmand et fils
sont individuellement ils ont tort et
ceux qui ont tort
il faut qu'ils soient jugés et coupable
mais collectivement il ne faut pas
qu'ils nuisent justement à ce mouvement
qui est une réussite sans ces
débordements gynéco non arrêtez de lire
tu regardes pas non mais c'est vrai
facile et où les passions dans les jets
avaient déjà j'avais déjà inscrits et
noté quelque chose au sujet des médias
je pense qu'on va le faire après les
médias donc vous avez vous dire dans un
an vous en avait déjà parlé à vous
maintenant on va le faire maintenant ça
va être la médiatisation déjà les choses
vous avez en avançant mais alors qu'on
est énorme et j'aimerais qu'on parle à
claude retraité 65 ans claude qui
voulait nous parler de cet incident
parce qu'on va terminer au dessus sur
les débordements et sur cet incident qui
s'est passé avec cette jeune femme dont
il y avait ça je le sais mais ça s'est
passé à prendre une chimie et sa vie
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement ce
que voulait rétablir la vérité sur jimmy
moi mais si on parlait tout à l'heure
oui c'est quand vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de la dame qui a été décidé donc
ça s'est passé tout près de chez vous à
pont-de-beauvoisin on était nous les
premiers informés de ce qui s'est passé
est en fait voilà moi je vais rétablir
la vérité
c'est une voiture donc dans laquelle il
y avait une femme avec un enfant et elle
partait chez le médecin donc les médias
disent qu'à la panique et que là ou pas
à la ségo et de pédales c'est pas vrai
du tout elle a foncé
puis elle est partie c'est attendait
l'esma finir ya deux ans elle est
arrivée donc chez le médecin et puis
quand on rentre sur quelqu'un quant au
rôle sur quelqu'un on s'arrête
normalement non elle a continué puis
elle est allée chez le médecin sauf
qu'il y avait des gilet jaune qui
étaient là et qu'ils l'ont suivi
et quand les policiers sont arrivés
parce qu'ils ont les policiers ont dit
donc elle a dit ah non non mais je sais
pas moi c'est pas moi c'est pas vrai
donc les gilet jaune on dit si c'est
vous madame et tous et depuis que l'on
embarqué c'est elle qui a foncé sur le
barrage
d'accord c'était voilà c'était foncer
dessus et la fille de cette dame
d'ailleurs qu'à beaucoup de cas
témoignait ouailles ont diminué même sa
maman venait de décéder
voilà c'est tout ce que je voulais c'est
bien notre bien va merci merci merci
claude oui mais vous savez on vit dans
une époque où on est alimenté par les
chaînes d'info en continu mais
finalement on voit des morts tous les
jours et du coup ça nous choque même
plus un débordement c'est grâce à des
mots c'est vrai et peu importe
finalement l'histoire une personne est
morte et vous dites que ces dames a
foncé délibérément la justice a retenu
que c'était une attaque de panique avait
été remise sous libera en liberté sous
contrôle judiciaire
donc il ya des dérapages qui sont
inacceptables et demain j'incite
vraiment les gilets jaunes demain à ne
pas bloquer les secouristes à ne pas
bloquer les infirmières libérales jamais
bloquée jamais on a toujours laissé une
voie pour l'épauler
s'il vous plaît vous dit vous ce n'était
pas un beau jeune homme est de votre
faute
il ya eu comme des événements temps mais
là c'est paris iv bolivie moi je vais
vous parler un peu de sécurité puisque
j'ai quand même travaillé sur la route
avec des engins dangereux et où la
sécurité elle a été respectée pour tous
les gens pouvaient circuler pouvait
aller oui vous voulez quand il voulait
il n'y avait aucun blocage de citoyens
lambda
et c'est sur les routes et les
ronds-points de l'occitanie et ça je le
maintiens
on a fait un message de paix de
pacifisme et de communication vers là
mais on a eu tout un citoyen lambda j'ai
chez moi finir s'il vous plaît un moment
oui il n'y a jamais eu un citoyen lambda
bloqués pris de panique qui a été blessé
ou qui a été touché par une cause des
gilet jaune est pas à un moment faut
arrêter de dire gilet jaune panique
gilet jaune fait des problèmes gilet
jaune s'il faut arrêter alors notre
bourg le maintien d'une mère de m
j'aimerais qu'on ait la sécurité de même
hier il est allé tuer vos messages ils
sont pas forcément écouté par tous les
îles et jaune ils sont écoutés par une
partie et il ya toujours des
débordements que vous le vouliez ou non
nous sommes toujours là pour toujours
merci à megan à différents endroits
excusez moi mais ouais mais différents
centres seraient pas dire si c'était
toujours qu'il ya un âge où il y en a
des problèmes il y en a deux
y'en a doit il y en a tous les jours